what are the council configurations to
make decisions in different policy areas
the Council meets in specialized
meetings known as council configurations
each configuration is made up of
ministers from the Member States it is
the ministers who vote on behalf of
their national government each
configuration deals with specific issues
for example economic and finance
ministers meet to discuss financial
affairs and ministers of justice discuss
justice issues in total the Council of
the EU meets in 10 different
configurations there is no hierarchy
among council configurations
however the General Affairs Council and
the Foreign Affairs Council have
specific roles defined in the EU
treaties meetings of each configuration
take place regularly some meet every
month some three to four times a year
and some on an ad-hoc basis over 150
preparatory bodies prepare the ground
for the meetings meetings are chaired by
the minister from the member state
holding the council presidency with the
exception of the Foreign Affairs Council
which is chaired by the High
Representative of the Union for Foreign
Affairs and security policy at their
meetings ministers work together to find
common solutions on issues of shared
interest the council takes decisions
using simple majority qualified majority
or unanimity voting when discussing or
voting on a legislative proposal council
meetings are public meetings are also
public when the council is debating
major issues affecting the interests of
the EU and its citizens find out all you
want to know about council
configurations and much more on
Concilium europa dot EU